non parce que la réforme du code du
travail la droite soutient jean michel
blanquer
il est tellement formidable qu'on
n'aurait même pas osé en rêver à droite
et la loue un seul anti terrorisme
objectivement globalement ça tient à peu
près la route il reste quoi peut-être le
projet doit être financé ce que là le
gouvernement sur une ligne de gauche
comme il reste sous les cieux le
gouvernement se donne 90 centre-gauche à
la tony blair comme ils ont encore
milieu en grande bretagne comme il ya eu
fraude heures en allemagne et la droite
elle a une femme a une faiblesse c'est
qu'elle sait sais pas comment le prendre
c'est qu'elle n'a pas de ligne
idéologique claire elle s'est passé et
libéral
elle sait pas si elle est conservatrice
sans n'avoir aucun jugement pour eux ni
pour l'un ni pour l'autre c'est bienvenu
au juge qu'il est libéral mais elle sait
même pas si elle est conservatrice ou
libéral sur les questions de sécurité
il ya des parlementaires on parle de
messieurs ciotti l'arrivée myona doute
de droite je vous dise mais c'est pas
normal que de deux mètres de faire en
sorte qu' il ya un contrôle permanent de
la société comme le fait ce projet de
loi c'est trop sécuritaire sur les
questions et donc s'il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de façon ils savent pas qu'elles
savent plus où il habite
mais ils ont en réalité ça fait 10 15
ans qui savent pas où ils habitent comme
il était au bout comme il était au
pouvoir ou dans une opposition sur les
en pariant sur l'alternance il se posait
pas de question aujourd'hui il se
retrouve avec un 1 1
comment un gouvernement qui est
difficile à attraper parce qu'il est sur
la ligne blairiste je rappelle que blair
il arrivé au pouvoir il a pris la tête
du parti socialiste en étant libéré sur
la question économique et en misant sur
la sécurité il l'a écrit dans ce bouquin
il a dit mon angle ça a été d'attaquer
sur la sécurité
macron il est assez inattaquable sur le
sujet ce pas dire que la raison surtout
qui fait tout bien sûr les députés qui
s'y connaissent à droite on des
critiques assez intéressante à formuler
mais c'est pas là dessus king qui se
feront remarquer est ce que ça peut être
sur la loi de finances
j'en suis pas convaincu mais à nouveau
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de vision et
d'assises a vu une vraie vision de la
société plus libérale
une vision qui défendent la
décentralisation est une vraie
décentralisation avec les pouvoirs aux
collectivités locales et pas uniquement
l'opposition le pouvoir central s'il
avait une vision de la société qui qui
domine l'état epalle inverse
il pourrait passer d'une vie il pourrait
critiquer avec un angle de droite
libérale une politique de ceux de
centre-gauche qui sait pas le cas
aujourd'hui il tire comme ils peuvent
mais elle est les tirs sont pas guidés
par une stratégie